VISHAL JAIN: Welcome everyone to
today's Talks at Google event.
I'm Vishal Jain, product
manager here at Google.
And I'm happy to host our
guest today, the founder
and CEO of KIND bar, and
also the author of this book,
"Do the KIND Thing,"
where he talks
about his experiences
starting the KIND bar company,
and some of the
lessons that can apply
to socially conscious
enterprises around the world.
So with that, I'd like to
introduce Daniel Lubetzky.
[APPLAUSE]
So today I thought that
a good format would
be for us to just
ask a few questions,
and we're going to do some
audience questions later
on as well.
And I apologize in
advance if it sounds
as though we're interviewing
you for a job at Google.
I assure you we're not.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: It would
be an honor and a pleasure
if I could even try to make it.
VISHAL JAIN: Well,
we'd love to have you,
if you decide that you
want to change careers.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: You
heard it here first.
VISHAL JAIN: So Daniel, one of
the really interesting things
about what you've done
is you've made a margin
in an industry that's very
different than our industry
here at Google, which is in the
consumer packaged goods world.
And obviously, we have
KIND bars distributed
around Google's micro kitchens,
and all of our offices.
And we love the product.
But as someone who's done
something really interesting--
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
Thank you, guys.
VISHAL JAIN: As someone
who's done something really
interesting in
the CPG world, I'm
just curious about when
you look at the landscape
today, what CPG companies
are really inspiring you?
And what brands do you think
have really done something
interesting out there?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: But you want
me to focus on CPG companies
in particular?
I find companies that are true
to their brands [? to be ?]
the ones that most interest me.
It doesn't necessarily need to
be a socially conscious brand.
I mean, I really
admire Starbucks.
They're a partner of ours.
And I really like a
lot of what they do.
I really like
Target as retailers.
There's so many different
companies I like.
But I like brands like Snickers.
I think Snickers is a
very authentic brand.
It's very much about--
it knows what it is.
Snickers satisfies you.
It does a very good job at
being fun and irreverent.
It doesn't try to
be something else.
So I think what
brands that I enjoy
the most are the ones that
really understand their value
proposition, and who they
are, and what customer
they cater for.
And then they just
live their brand.
I like Lululemon a lot
in terms of what they've
achieved in such a short time.
But it's not necessarily the
socially conscious brand for me
that I would [INAUDIBLE].
It's most about authenticity.
VISHAL JAIN: That
makes a lot of sense.
And I can see how
Snickers, in that sense,
must have been one
of your inspirations
as well when you were starting--
DANIEL LUBETZKY: I
wouldn't go that far.
I mean, I have my Snickers, but
they're a very different value
proposition from ours.
But I just think that they know
who they are, what are they,
and they don't try
to be something else.
I think what's dangerous
is when a brand-- consumer
tastes are changing a lot.
And Snickers is
always going to have
a great market for
the mass consumer that
wants a candy bar.
And it's a great product.
But for people that
want to eat more
nutritionally dense
products, there's
a completely different product.
And what I think
would be dangerous
is for Snickers to try
to become what it's not.
That's why I admire them.
Not because I aspire or
took that much inspiration
from them, other than that
they learned who they are.
When I started my first company,
I didn't really think enough
about these issues.
And I was trying to be
everything for everybody.
And I talk a lot about the
most embarrassing examples
in the book.
But I really was trying to
do a lot of things at once
and cater to a lot of
different type of consumers.
And I wasn't sufficiently
mindful about the importance
of being obsessive
about what your brand is
and what it should stand for.
And somebody once said
that a brand is a promise.
And a great brand is
a promise well-kept.
And that has really
stayed with me,
particularly after the
many mistakes and failures
in my earlier career, when
I was not being sufficiently
obsessive about staying within
the guard rails of the brand
promise that we made.
VISHAL JAIN: That's
really well-put.
I like that.
It's interesting you talk
about the combination
of different value propositions.
And in the book you talk a
lot about the "and" principle.
And it sounds as though
you're basically saying,
you've got to pick sort of
the right two or three things
that you really want to
combine together that haven't
been combined together before.
Obviously, for KIND bar, taste
and health in the same product
was, I think, the big,
unique value proposition
you brought to the market.
I was just curious.
When you look at the
Google product portfolio,
and when you look at the
technology industry as a whole,
do you see opportunities
in technology
where the "and" principle
could be applied?
And are there any
products, for example,
that Google makes that you
think represents the same sort
of "and" principles that
KIND bar started with?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: You
ask easy questions.
Only softballs.
Let me try to go back
for once again, just
to make sure that
everybody knows
what the "and" philosophy is.
So at KIND, what we try to do is
to question false assumptions,
and to try to get at what
those false assumptions is.
Because there's a lot of
opportunity to create value
certainly in the
technology world,
even more than any, by
trying to see how have people
have been doing something.
And do we really need
to accept it as dogma
that this is the way
it has to be done?
And very often, because
our brains are efficient,
they shortcut to the easiest
answer, or the fastest answer,
rather than the one that would
be best in the long-term.
Sometimes in the long-term,
if you work harder upfront,
you can achieve goals that
may be seemingly at tension.
And so the "and"
philosophy is about
trying to combine goals that are
seemingly impossible to achieve
at the same time.
So for KIND, it's about
doing something that's
nutritionally rich and
delicious, where it's
both nutritious and
delicious; or something
that is economically sustainable
and socially impactful;
or a product that
actually travels
well that's convenient to travel
with, but that's wholesome.
So those are goals
that normally people
think are at tension
and incompatible,
and if you really work hard
enough, you can achieve.
When you are able to
uncover it, you actually
unleash a lot of value.
So in the technology
world, you look
at the way things
are and then say,
well is it really true
that it has to be this way?
You ask the questions
why and why not.
And if you're able to find
the underlying assumptions,
you're already well
underway to trying
to challenge those
assumptions and see
if they can be actually broken.
And so in your world,
an example-- well, first
of all, I think the way Google's
philosophy works-- and we were
talking about this a
second ago-- I think really
is in the long-term-- it's
very long-term oriented, right?
They don't try to
win 100% of the time
at all time in the short-term.
They try to give the
consumer the best solution.
And they know if they
do that, then people
will continually going to
use their search products.
So they combine between--
I guess in some ways saying
and-- in the search platform.
You can get links,
or you can actually
sometimes get the answers.
And how do you decide
whether-- you could probably
sell more ads if you
generated more pages.
But sometimes the consumer
wants a more immediate answer.
And if you're able
to serve that up,
even if you're not going
to generate more pages,
or if you're going to compete
with yourselves or with others,
you're trying to find
that right medium.
But the standard is always,
what is the best consumer
experience?
What does that end user want?
And I think that should
always be the standard.
I remember on YouTube--
I'm going to date myself,
because you guys were
probably not born--
but there once was a time
when on YouTube, you couldn't
click inside the videos.
Did you realize that?
There was a time where
YouTube didn't exist.
You guys probably don't know.
But there was a need.
There was this ability, why not?
Why not be able to view
the experience and interact
with it?
And somebody-- Chad
Hurley or someone,
who used to support us many
years ago on the social front
and other work I've done--
figured out at some point
that there's a way with "and" to
have the video experience also
be interactive.
So certainly
technology's probably
one of the best grounds for
disruptiveness and for you
to think with "and."
The challenge is for
us as human beings,
because-- sorry I'm giving
you a very long answer.
VISHAL JAIN: No, no.
It's really interesting.
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
I should give you
profound and concise answers.
But I'm not good at that stuff.
But the challenge is not that
technology can't do stuff.
The challenge is
that our brains have
been so trained to do things
every day the same way,
that for us to step
back is so important.
And even with our technologies,
we get used to how things are.
That's why fresh
eyes and fresh brains
can really, really be disruptive
and win, often when you are
able to see things differently.
And in the book, I
talk a lot about how
to try to find a way to
keep that fresh perspective,
even when you're used to
doing something and some tools
we use at KIND to try
to think differently.
VISHAL JAIN: Very cool.
And I notice a lot
of similarities there
actually, between the
way Google and KIND look
at the consumer value
proposition and the attention--
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Well,
thank you for saying that.
Because obviously Google
does a really awesome job.
VISHAL JAIN: Thank you.
Maybe more of a
softball question.
In the book, you
talked a little bit
about the origin of your
food industry experience
and the work that you
did with PeaceWorks
where you worked with Israeli
and Palestinian businesses
to build bridges between
those two cultural groups.
One of the things
I was curious about
was what was sort of your
business model as a consultant
there?
You obviously had
a social cause.
But you also needed
to make money.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: The
PeaceWorks business model?
VISHAL JAIN: Yeah.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: So
right after law school,
my first company after law
school was and is still called,
PeaceWorks.
And it tries to bring
neighbors in conflict regions
to work together.
And I actually did try
first as a consultant.
But here was this confused
Mexican Jewish lawyer
trying to consult to
Arabs and Israelis.
Nobody wanted to have
anything to do with it.
So I tried to build
a consulting business
to try to get Arabs and
Israelis to work together.
And the Americans were
going to be the catalysts
to these joint ventures.
But the consulting
thing went nowhere.
And I decided to end
up actually starting
such a venture--
PeaceWorks venture-- where
we brought trading partners
to trade with one another.
And the way it started was
I was doing this research,
and I came across this jar of a
sun-dried tomato spread, which
back in the early
'90s, at least to me,
I had never heard of
sun-dried tomatoes.
Today, again, we take
that for granted.
But in '93, when I came across
this jar of sun-dried tomato
spread, I had never heard
of sun-dried tomatoes.
I bought the jar.
I downed the whole thing in one
evening in my late research.
And I tried to buy some more.
And there was no
more in the store.
So long story short, I
almost choked to death
the manager at the
store for him to give me
the name of the
former manufacturer.
No, I'm joking.
It was not violent.
But I did insist a lot
to get the information.
And I got to the
ex-manufacturer of this product.
And it turned out he was
buying his sun-dried tomatoes
from Italy and his glass
jars from Portugal.
And it was very expensive.
And I showed him that he could
buy his glass jars from Egypt
and buy his sun-dried
tomatoes from Turkey.
And we started sourcing
olives and olive oil
from Palestinian and
Arab-Israeli farmers.
And the model was that
this Israeli manufacturer--
this Israeli-Jewish
manufacturer--
would trade with Arab
citizens of Israel,
with Palestinians living
in the West Bank and Gaza,
with Turks, Egyptians,
and other Arab neighbors.
And by them trading
with one another,
the concept of PeaceWorks
was that they would
shatter cultural stereotypes.
They would discover
each other's humanity.
And then they would cement
business relationships
because they would be
working with one another.
So we launched in '93, '94,
this line called first Moshe
and Ali's.
The original name was very,
very succinct-- Moshe Pupik
and Ali Mishmumken's
World-Famous Gourmet Foods.
And nobody could pronounce it.
And I learned about simplicity
through that lesson.
And I talk about that
story there also.
But that was the model.
The model was a trading model.
I would buy the products
from my trading partners
and sell them in
the United States.
And then they would
work together.
And the nice thing
about the social concept
was that the more that we
would sell these products,
the more that we
could buy from them,
the more that we could foster
that trade among neighbors.
VISHAL JAIN: Very cool.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: And
you can see that it
was so successful that we
have peace in the Middle East.
Everything's solved.
VISHAL JAIN: Well, we
have sun-dried tomatoes.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: You have--
and at a macro level,
we have not scaled
the way we would like.
I'm actually now
going to reinvest
in doing PeaceWorks 2.0, because
I really have neglected it
the last 20-plus years.
But at the personal level,
many of the relationships
that started 21 years ago
are still there today.
And throughout the
vicissitudes of the conflict,
Yoel Benesh continuing trading
with Abdullah Ghanim's family.
Abdullah passed on, passed away.
But his son still
trades with them.
So those relationships
at the personal level
did get cemented.
VISHAL JAIN: Very cool.
And you mentioned sun-dried
tomatoes, which is obviously
in the food industry.
Is that then how you
organically kind of moved
into nuts and fruits,
and eventually
what became the
constituents of KIND bar?
And how did you
decide that snack bars
is where you wanted to start?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Yeah.
If you had told me
right after law school
that I was going to be in
the food space, I would say,
you're cuckoo.
I mean, it never was part
of my dream growing up.
I was a magician.
And I sold watches.
And I did a lot of crazy jobs.
But at the beginning,
food was a conduit
towards pursuing my mission of
bringing neighbors together.
And then I fell in love with it.
And I really started liking it.
It took awhile.
But at the beginning
I was suffering a lot,
because I was making
so many mistakes.
And fortunately I didn't
realize how bad I had it.
But the first 11
years when I was
like going up and down the
streets of Manhattan, selling
store by store
with my briefcase,
with my leather briefcase--
or fake leather briefcase,
not even leather briefcase,
my fake leather briefcase--
and take out the
legal books and put
jars of sun-dried tomato
spread and bread for people
to sample the product.
And I would go starting at
7:00 AM in the morning on 122nd
Street on Broadway, and walk
the west side of Broadway
all the way down to Wall Street.
And then I would cross.
And then I would
walk all the way up.
And after a couple
days of taking orders,
the next day I would
take my beat-up Cougar,
and I would put the
product in the trunk.
And I would seal
it with duct tape
because the trunk was broken.
And I would deliver the product.
And I forgot why I'm telling
you this whole story.
What were we talking about?
Oh yeah, I have the transition.
So then after 11
years of mistakes,
I learned about the food space.
And I was traveling to do
ventures all over in the Middle
East, and in Sri Lanka, and
Indonesia, and in Mexico,
not focusing, trying to do
a lot of things at once.
And as I was traveling, or I
was skipping lunch, or skipping
dinner, or traveling
in the US to sell,
I felt very frustrated with
my own snacking options.
And I always sensed
that there were
opportunities to do
healthful snacking better.
And it wasn't satisfying me.
I wasn't finding something that
I could feel good about eating.
And so I kept being
on the search.
And once we came up
with KIND, I knew
that there was going
to be something
that would satisfy
others too, because I
felt that there was that need.
And today, by the way, 11 years
later, it's just the beginning.
I mean the revolution of
eating more mindfully, more
healthfully, and snacking,
and healthful snacking,
and responsible snacking,
is just at the beginning.
Even though it's
very disruptive,
we're just entering it.
I think it's going
to be far, far
more disruptive in
the coming years,
because those trends
are so powerful.
All of us are busy, and
so we are on the go.
But we want to eat something
wholesome, and nutritious,
and real.
And at the same time-- so
the need for convenience
and the need for
healthfulness is really
providing a lot of opportunities
for a lot of people.
VISHAL JAIN: That's
really fascinating.
So it actually had a lot to do
with your own personal travels
and the fact that
you're always on the go.
So that format is something
you had a need for.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Still
today, I have four children.
When I get home at 6:00
PM, I have a very nice meal
waiting for me.
But for lunch, and Julianne
and Rebecca can attest to it.
Every day for lunch I tend
to have one or two KIND bars.
That's my lunch.
They also don't let
me do anything else.
I try sometimes to escape.
They're like, no!
You shall eat the KIND bars.
VISHAL JAIN: I want to
shift a little bit away
from the business
and into the book.
We all have the story to
tell, but not everyone
takes the time to
sit down and actually
write it through thoroughly.
And you've obviously put
a lot of thought and time
into producing this.
So I guess why the transition
from the food industry
into the publishing
industry, so to speak?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Well,
it's not-- I mean,
this is more a way to help
us deepen into the work
that we're doing.
But I think two primary reasons.
One is a lot of people
gave a lot to me in my 11
years of the wilderness.
Even still today, I
have a lot of mentors.
And Ben Cohen, the
guy that started
Ben and Jerry's, and
many other people were
on my advisory board, and just
taught me a lot of what I know.
And now when young
entrepreneurs come to me
and ask me questions, I
don't have enough time
to go as deep as I would like.
And I felt that the book
really is a very raw exposition
of a lot of the failures-- which
I think from the failures you
derive more lessons--
as well as the insights
and some of the successes.
So it was a way for
people that want
to learn from my
mistakes-- whether it's
social entrepreneurs or people
in the food space, or just
people that when I learned
how to think with "and,"
or think creatively,
or just draw
from any of those experiences.
And the second is that for
our aspiration and our dream
for what we want KIND to become,
we don't want to be a company.
We want to become a movement.
We don't want to just
be a business that
has a social responsibility.
We want to transcend the way
people think of businesses
or products to something that
they connect with viscerally,
that belongs to them, that
becomes a state of mind.
And it probably
sounds like you think
that I had something
very weird for breakfast,
but in the coming years
you'll see some of the ideas
that we have, and how we're
going to implement that.
And the first step in
trying to build that
was to show people
our vision of what
we're trying to create
so that hopefully they'll
be more excited about
joining us on that journey
and learning about it.
So telling people
about-- our products
are sold, we understand why you
guys buy our products, or why
that you get them here
at, what do you call them?
VISHAL JAIN: Micro kitchens.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Micro kitchens.
Because they're
delicious, and they're
made with nutritionally
rich ingredients.
And so we never forget that.
And also because in my
early years at PeaceWorks,
I was so obsessive
about the mission
of bringing Arabs and
Israelis together that that's
all I would talk about.
I made the mistake of not
focusing on the product.
And at KIND, I
promised myself that I
would focus on the product.
So for the last
10, 11 years we've
talked very little about
our social mission.
And through the book, it's
giving me an opportunity
to talk a little
bit more broadly
about where we're
coming from, what's
important to us,
what we're aiming
to do in society, as a first
step in the remaining journey
that we have.
VISHAL JAIN: OK.
Cool.
And just so you guys
know in the audience,
we'll be getting audience
questions in a little bit.
Just want to step
up to the microphone
and start thinking about what
questions you might have.
And one of the other things
you spoke about in the book
that I was curious
to learn more about,
and was hoping you could
tell us more about,
is the Universal
Values Curriculum.
Can you just tell us a little
bit about what that is?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Yeah.
So that's unrelated to-- not
so directly related to KIND,
but it's something else
that I care a lot about.
I think that-- let me
take one step back,
because I've been talking about
this a lot in the last week.
But maybe you guys have
never heard about it.
But a lot of what drives me is
that my father was a Holocaust
survivor.
And he was in a
concentration camp in Dachau.
So the common thread
in all I do is
trying to build bridges
not to be nice to society,
but as a survival instinct.
I want my children to
not have happen to them
what happened to my father.
I want other human
beings not to have
happen to them what
happened to my father.
So one of the
things that I think
a lot about as we
see what's going on
in the Middle East with ISIS,
the Islamic State, and so many
divisions within societies
and between societies,
and what's happening in Israel
and the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, and more broadly--
and also when you think more
broadly about climate change,
about resource scarcity, 2
billion people are elevating
their standard of living.
And what that means
is that more people
are going to demand more premium
products that require more
from our Earth.
And water scarcity
in California,
water scarcity
globally, scarcity
of natural resources and
food, nuclear proliferation--
these things are
major challenges
that we're going
to face in society.
And the only chance we have
as a human race to survive
is to recognize
our shared humanity
and to work together as one.
And divisions that are in some
ways actually deepening over
the last few years between
the West and the East,
and in the Middle East, I
think need to be challenged.
And the way you challenge
those is not just
through military means.
I personally-- my
father survived
because American
soldiers rescued him.
So I'm very grateful for the
military's sacrifice for people
that they had never
met, like my father.
And so I do think
there's a role to play
in using force very cautiously
to fight totalitarianism.
But it's never
going to be enough.
And the way to really,
really win ultimately
is to have an
alternative ideology.
And one of my thoughts was--
this is a very long way
to answer your
question, but it's
a deep conversation--
is if you look today
at the community of nations,
at the United Nations,
there's 200 members
of the United Nations.
And they've created laws
on the law of the sea
and on all these other compacts.
But on this core issue of
shared values and education,
we've done nothing, in the
sense that today there's
nothing that a kid in Israel,
or in Palestine, or in Iran,
or in the United States
necessarily share.
They don't necessarily get
taught what brings us together
as a human race.
Why not create the common core
curriculum where we encourage,
and ultimately if
we succeed, mandate,
that all third graders,
or all first graders,
are going to share in this
common core curriculum
to discover each other's
humanity to learn.
Now we can use technology
to connect them.
Google can be a partner.
Skype can be a partner.
Others can be partners.
To try to build more
threads between kids
all across the world, starting
with educational materials
where they ask themselves,
what makes me a human being?
What do I have in
common with other kids?
And for them to ask
those questions,
for them to be the ones
who discover the answers,
and then connecting
kids through technology
so that kids across
the world all
are part of sharing
the same set of values
of learning what brings us
together as human beings.
So the idea of this
Universal Values Curriculum
is something that
I'm starting slowly.
I've been working
on it for 10 years.
But hopefully this
year we're going
to start funding it and working
with educators to create
this common
curriculum that we'll
offer for free for schools
that commit to teach it.
And we'll even provide
them incentives or tools,
educational materials.
There's already a potential
partner in Pakistan
that has a half a million
students that they fund.
And there's different programs
all over the world that we hope
will join this
and be part of it.
And the dream is that X number
of years from now, the United
Nations-- all members of
the community of nations--
will mandate that all
kids across the world
will learn about
their shared humanity
and become part of something
bigger than ourselves.
Simple idea.
VISHAL JAIN: It is actually
a simple idea really,
at its root.
But it's just probably
too complicated
to actually bring it to life.
I guess wrapping up
with my questions,
you spoke a little bit about
what's next for KIND bar
and how the book plays
into the long-term mission.
But just whatever you can
share with us about what some
of those big next milestones,
either for the book,
or for the company are.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: By the
way, it's not KIND bar.
It's KIND.
And we have a couple
team members that
work for the clusters team.
And they might otherwise
really come after you
if I don't clarify that.
Some of you got the parfait
with the KIND healthy grain
clusters.
But we never wanted
to be a bar company.
We happen to know that bars are
a very efficient way for people
to travel, and so we're very
proud of being part of that.
But that's not what defines us.
What defines us is the common
thread among all KIND products
is ingredients you
can see and pronounce.
That's our trademark.
So whether it's in bar format
like the original fruit nut
bars, or I don't
know if you've seen,
or you have carry in
your micro kitchens,
the STRONG & KIND bars
that have savory flavors.
So if you're feeling
like something savory,
instead of a bag
of potato chips,
you can get something
more nutritionally
rich that has 10 grams
of protein, all natural.
So that's the
STRONG & KIND bars.
I'm giving you my ad.
Or whether it's a
KIND Healthy Grain
bars, which are kind of like
a better type of granola
that has five super grains like
amaranth, and quinoa, and chia,
and gluten free oat, et
cetera, and buckwheat;
or the KIND Healthy Grain
Clusters, which are-- So
in our vision,
what's next for us,
is if you look at all those four
areas where we've innovated,
we tried, we would like to
believe, that we brought
something totally new that
didn't exist in the marketplace
before, that was fresh,
and that people wanted,
even though they didn't
know it until we created it.
So that's our standard.
We want to innovate
in new categories.
But we only want to do
it when we really are not
going to do a meet two item,
or just try to copy and do
something like somebody else.
We want to do it where we
really can disrupt the space
and really elevate the standards
for that particular category.
This fall we're launching
another new product
line, again, into a new space.
And every year or
two, our ambition
is to be able to enter a
new category with products
that are elevating the
standards of healthful eating.
But we have sometimes gotten
it wrong, and not launched.
So we also have the discipline
to say if we don't-- it's very
different from technology.
In technology, you can go and
try something, and fail fast,
and start again.
And you're giving
out the product
for free in some
sense, so you can
allow people to say I didn't
like it, beta test, whatever.
But in food, what I found
in consumer goods is
when you try our
product, it's a promise
that we gave you
that you're going
to have a great experience.
And if we disappoint
you, you're not
going to not just not
try that product again,
but you might abandon our brand.
So we are very, very obsessive
the way we launch products.
It has to be exceeding
people's expectations.
And when we do all the work,
when all is said and done,
we don't think that it's
going to raise the bar
and exceed your expectations.
We just have the discipline
to not launch it.
So we hopefully will
continue innovating,
but with the humility to know
that if you get it wrong,
you should just not do it.
VISHAL JAIN: That's a pretty
hard discipline to stick to.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Especially
when you've invested yourself
so hard into something.
And you're like, ah, all right.
Let's walk away.
VISHAL JAIN: With that, do any
of the folks in the audience
have--
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Elijah, please.
It's the Passover
allusion to the person
that's not by the microphone.
Sorry.
I can't much Jon Stewart.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a huge KIND fan.
Thanks so much for coming today.
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: My question is about
this ambitious growth strategy
that you've just
described to us.
How do you plan to finance it?
And do you grow concerned
that at a certain point
there's a tension between
involving other investors who
may have a different position
on how best to grow the company,
and your personal vision for
how the company should grow.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: So I'm very
lucky because I screwed up
so bad for the first
11, 12, 13, 14, 15 years
that nobody wanted to
invest in my company.
So I ended up owning most
of it till the company was
healthy enough that I didn't
dilute myself so much.
But we brought in
investors in 2008.
And then they were
great partners.
They taught me a ton.
And we had a
commitment that they
would be with us for up to five
years, four and a half years.
So I think it was 2012, '13,
where we bought them back.
And it was a very
difficult thing to do,
because the company
had performed well.
So they made a lot of money.
But they deserved it.
They added a lot of value.
And we financed
that in two ways.
One is we took debt
for the first time,
because I'm very averse to debt.
But we took some debt on.
And we also brought
in a new investor
that could help take
us to the next level,
the [? grad ?] be smart money.
And we were very upfront with
them about what our values are,
and the fact that we are doing
this for more than just money,
and that our social
mission is not negotiable.
And they understood that
the social mission actually
feeds loyalty and that
it has a positive impact
on the business, also.
And also it happens
to be good that I'm
the majority shareholder.
They do have protections
as investors,
but ultimately I listen to them.
I don't think I've ever
reached a decision that
wasn't unanimous, like our board
really has saved me from myself
sometimes, because it's
very important to be
creative and come up with
all these crazy ideas,
but you also need
to have filters.
And they talk a lot
in the book about how
to divide the creative process
from the filtering process.
And they have to
be very separate,
and how to really,
really come up
with completely
differentiated ideas,
and then how to test them.
And I think it's very important
to separate those stages.
But currently we're
cash flow positive.
So we don't need more money.
So the question is, what
am I going to do with it?
And we explored going public.
And for now, as of
right now, we don't
think that that's the
right answer for us.
We're having a lot of fun
and building a community
and a movement internally also.
Like we have-- every
team member that
works at KIND who's
a full-time member
is a fellow shareholder
in the company.
And so for now at least, we're
going to continue doing it
ourselves.
But who knows what
happens tomorrow?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
So I really loved
what you were saying
about brand authenticity.
And we work with a lot of brands
that have clear brand equity
but have fallen out of
public favor-- cereal brands,
for instance.
So I'm just curious what your
advice would be to those brands
in really tapping into
what makes them authentic.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: Yeah.
That's a very good question.
I actually think about
that question a lot
because it's so easy for me
to say, be true to your brand.
But what if your brand
falls in disfavor?
First of all,
everything is relative.
Right?
The cereal space is
still a $29 billion
space or $22 billion space.
It's very big.
It's bigger than the
nutritional bar space.
Now nutritional
bars are growing,
and cereals are
slowly contracting.
So yes, it's not a growing area.
But it's a gigantic area.
A lot of people
still have cereal.
So these guys have
very smart people too.
And I think I've seen
some of the moves
that Kellogg's and
General Mills have
taken to try to take their
cereal equity into convenience
and make their products more
convenient to carry and travel
on the go.
I think that's good.
I think that's smart.
And I think they're going to
see some payoff from that.
What would not work is-- I
think what you need to do first
and foremost is to understand
your brand well, and understand
what is a consumer
expecting from you,
and does your brand have
license to go somewhere else?
So an indulgent
brand that is selling
sugary beverages,
or cereal, or stuff
like that, that brand
should probably not
try to reposition itself
as a healthy brand,
because the consumer is
not going to trust it.
A brand that does that and
tries to proclaim itself
to be something
else, you probably
will actually hurt
the parent brand
because it will
seem unauthentic.
So I think the most
important thing
is to be authentic,
to understand
what is it that you are, and
what does your core consumer
care about.
And then do that
for your consumer.
And then if you're
a gigantic company
and you feel that you need
to go in a another category,
sometimes it's better to just
acquire or start a new brand
than to have a brand
that has negative equity
in the particular place
where you want to go.
But I don't believe that you
need to go to all places.
I've seen a lot of friends at
other companies say, oh wow.
Right now the hot
thing is organic.
And oh wow, right
now it's gluten free.
And then they come up
with gluten free salsa.
Well yeah.
Salsa is gluten free because
it doesn't have gluten.
But consumers are very
sophisticated in the end
of the day.
You can actually fool
them once or twice,
but in the longer
term, in the mid-term,
they're going to figure it out.
So I think you need
to really, really
be authentic and understand
what your brand stands for,
and have a conversation
with your own consumers
and with yourself,
and then figure out
how to deliver to
them what that is.
Again, in the
cereal space, there
are so many opportunities
within that brand equity,
I just would try to stay there.
Fortunately, I don't have to
answer that question for real.
[? Because ?] there are $60
billion dollar companies,
$100 billion companies that
have a lot of these legacy
challenges.
And it's not easy.
And a lot of the people
leading these companies
are formidable
good human beings,
they're just inheriting
these challenges.
And it's not easy.
AUDIENCE: So we have a
couple of young vegetarians,
so KIND has been a great way
to get at least a little bit
of protein into them.
So thank you for that.
I'm a big fan of the salted
chocolate caramel, personally.
But you actually
anticipated my question,
which is as a consumer,
the only reason I
hesitate to buy sometimes is you
don't have an organic option.
So what has been your take on
the whole organic movement?
And is that something that
might be in the works?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: No.
I mean, we think about these
questions all the time.
For us, we needed to choose what
we're going to be as a brand.
And what we chose is to provide
people nutritionally rich,
premium ingredients.
And in our particular
categories where we play,
we felt that was what was
most important and most
differentiated for us to add.
And you know, I respect a
lot of other fair trade,
organic, other things
that are important.
We try to behave
environmentally responsibly.
We're doing a whole 360
evaluation ourselves
about how to do things
in an environmentally
responsible way.
We try to source everything with
KIND in a responsible manner,
in a fair manner.
But to certify
ourselves organic,
to certify ourselves fair
trade, to certify everything,
the product would be outside
of the reach of people.
We already are the
most expensive product
because we give you a lot more
whole almonds and whole nuts
and treat the product
with a lot of respect.
And so we needed
to choose what was
the most important thing for
us to provide to the consumer.
There's also an issue
of sustainability
that concerns me a lot.
Like right now,
there's not enough
honey in the world-- there's
not enough organic honey.
There's not enough organic
almonds to supply what we buy.
And it's shocking how
dangerous the situation is.
I was alluding to
scarcity of food.
It's a very serious problem.
There's huge drought
problems in California.
There's bee collapse
challenges that are finally
starting to come out.
But still, the amount
of production of almonds
and of honey in the last several
years has been so challenged.
And in the meantime,
consumption is skyrocketing.
So that's why these
things are becoming
more and more expensive.
And as we're going to need to
feed 2 billion more people,
there's a lot of questions
that as a society
we need to ask
ourselves about how
we're going to be feeding all
of those 2 billion people.
Right now what our
team is obsessing about
is being able to even
source quality products
on a sustainable basis.
So there's a lot of questions
that we're challenged with,
try to balance.
As a brand, we want to
just continue always
being nutrition-rich ingredients
that you can see and pronounce.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My kids love
the KIND clusters.
So thank you for making things
that my kids will actually eat.
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
Thank you so much.
And I didn't pay any of
them to say these things.
AUDIENCE: You talked a
little bit about mistakes
that you made when you
were a fledgling startup.
Can you talk a little
bit about anything
that really sticks
to your mind, lessons
that you learned as
you were growing?
And especially in the arena of
shifting categories from bars
to clusters, for instance.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: I actually
talk-- first of all, my biggest
mistakes where I drew
the most-- and that's
why I really share
them in the book--
was in the first 11 years,
when I didn't know anything,
and I just kept making
mistake after mistake.
And from those lessons, I
think a lot of KIND success
was because we
were more focused.
Whereas in the
first 10, 11 years,
we were very undisciplined
in every way,
trying to develop too many
products as opposed to staying
focused the way we
do it now-- trying
to go into too many
stores, any store that
would have us as opposed to
having a migration strategy
and being focused
on how we expand.
To your question about going
from bars to clusters--
and I talk about this in a
lot more depth in the book--
but I'll tell you
two quick thoughts.
One is, there was
a reason why we
chose to go with
the clusters first
rather than into
another set of bars.
That we wanted to
communicate to the consumer
that we were not a bar company
but a healthy snacking company,
and a healthy eating company,
whose common thread was not
the bar format, but the use of
nutritionally rich ingredients
that you could
see and pronounce.
So we were thinking about
doing another granola bar.
And we thought, then
people are going
to think we're the
KIND bar company.
Even right now, they still--
not to put you on the spot.
VISHAL JAIN: My apologies
to the clusters team.
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
But a lot of people
still think of us
as a bar company.
And we early on decided
to do the clusters.
It's a much smaller category.
The bag granola category, I
think it's like $400 million
compared to the granola
bar category, which
is like $4 billion.
So granola bars are
a much bigger space.
Logically, we should
have gone there.
But we consciously decided
to first go to clusters
because we wanted to convey
to the consumer this point.
And when you're
building products,
oftentimes the second line
you introduce is as or more
important than the
first, because you're
connecting the dots.
Actually, Eric Berman, who
I think actually works here
at Google, first
taught me that point.
OK, this is what the KIND
Fruit + Nut Bars are.
But what is a common thread?
It could be that we use fruits.
It could be that we use nuts.
It could be that we use
nutritionally rich ingredients.
It could be the bar
format, so on and so forth.
By launching the
clusters, we connected,
and we said, the common
thread is ingredients
you can see an pronounce.
It's nutritionally
rich ingredients.
It's not necessarily
the bar format.
We made a mistake when
we started with clusters
several years ago in not
sufficiently understanding
how sensitive those grains
that we were sourcing were.
And the use of grains
that we use-- amaranth,
is very, very
susceptible to go rancid.
And so you need to treat
it with a lot of respect.
You really, really,
really need to protect it.
And early on when we launched
the clusters, like a month
into it, we started getting
complaints from consumers
that they felt the
product was rancid.
And we were freaking out,
because of the promise
that I told you that
I promised myself
I would make to our consumers.
And we got on average for
a KIND bar product line--
I'm doing it from
memory, so I may get it
a little off-- but it's
something like less
than one complaint per million.
It's I think 0.01
complaint per million.
We almost don't get complaints.
All of a sudden we got
200 complaints per million
on the clusters.
And for us that was a very,
very large and alarming thing.
Maybe in another company
it would be acceptable.
For us, we were really
obsessing about quality.
We didn't want to
disappoint consumers.
Because every one person that
complains, at least that person
you can talk to them, and you
can fix the issue with them,
and you can even build a
relationship with that person.
But for every person
that complains,
there's another
1,000 or 10,000 that
just stop buying your product.
Those are the people
that I worry about.
So we very quickly, we had
a couple people camp out,
I remember.
Several of our team members
went there for weeks on end
to try to fix the issue.
And I was really appreciative
of their major sacrifice
on behalf of the
company to fix it.
And within two, three months,
we improved our practices
for sourcing these grains.
Within a few months,
the number of complaints
was back down to like
0.01 per million,
or whatever is in the book.
But it was a humbling lesson in,
when you're entering adjacency,
be careful about sourcing
ingredients with care.
VISHAL JAIN: And actually
just to follow up
on that, when you're
structuring your organization
to be able to take these kinds
of smart, methodical bets,
do you have sort of a classic
brand management, you know,
category managers,
brand managers, and sort
of innovation managers?
Or do you try to structure
the team differently
to suit the KIND strategy?
DANIEL LUBETZKY: First
of all, we just brought
in an amazing head of marketing.
Her name is Lisa Mann.
She had an incredible career.
She could probably
answer your question
10 times better than I can.
And what I love about KIND
is that we attract people
and bring people that
are better than I
am at the areas of
their expertise.
And so she is going to
be working with our team
in reviewing all
the way we currently
do things to see how
we do them differently.
But the way we've done
it in the past-- I
really try to get our team to
think more from the gut than
from the data.
We have awesome
team members that
bring so many data insights.
And by the way, I
really appreciate them
because they're very
different from me.
I don't think enough
from the data,
and data is very important.
But when you're
designing something new,
the data is obviously very
important when you're selling.
It's very useful data.
And it's to some degree useful
also when you're planning.
But when you're innovating,
data only tells you
the history of where
you're coming from.
It doesn't tell you
where you need to go.
And it also doesn't tell you
who are, your brand promise.
So you need to be very careful
when you're looking at data not
to try to chase a
fad that's ephemeral
or that belongs
to somebody else.
So I really try to work
with my team for them
to think completely
out of the box.
So we have a very
[? atraditional ?] structure
on the new product development
side because we're trying
to think [? atraditionally. ?]
And a lot of the
innovation that's coming,
it's coming from team members
that are just completely
thinking outside the box.
And we try not to put them in
too structured an environment,
because I don't
want them to think
that just because
they come from here,
the next thing is
in that same space.
VISHAL JAIN: Any other
questions from the audience?
DANIEL LUBETZKY:
Should we wrap up?
We have two more
minutes if anybody
wants to win a free car.
Was that what their--
VISHAL JAIN: Is that
coming from KIND?
Or is that--
DANIEL LUBETZKY: No.
It's a Google-- it's
a Google car, right?
Random House is here.
They're my partners
from Ballantine Books.
So thank you for
being great partners.
VISHAL JAIN: The books
are at sale in the back.
DANIEL LUBETZKY: The
books are on sale.
And you saw all of our KIND team
treating you to some products.
So thank you to Julianna
and Rebecca for putting this
together, and to all or our
team members in the fields team
that are every day
nourishing the community.
Thank you so much
for having us, guys.
VISHAL JAIN: Thanks
for coming, Daniel.
[APPLAUSE]